hi i'm maria sharapova and this is my
glamofesto for life
[Music]
my daily mantra is one step at a time
i feel that sometimes i get way too
ahead of myself
with my goals and my priorities and
sometimes
it certainly gets in the way of being
present my
instant mood booster must be a workout
i usually start my day with a sweat and
whether that's
15 20 minutes whether sometimes that's
an hour or
hour and a half if i want to push myself
i feel like it sets a really good
good base for the rest of the day i get
bored very easily as i think we all do
with our workout routines
you must be consistent so i try to mix
up two or three different workouts and
after retirement i feel like i work on
my arms a little bit more because i
don't really do much of that in my
everyday life
i can't live without honesty it was a
really
important quality to have about your
mindset about who you are about the
people that you're with
and that all comes down to authenticity
glamour means
well it's very different what it meant
12 months ago to what it means today
glamour now is just getting out of the
house and putting a little lipstick on
whereas before it was healed and having
your hair done i don't wear heels
very often but when i do then that means
i'm very glamorous
hydration is certainly one of the keys
to life through working with evian for
over nine years as a global ambassador
i've been provided the tools and the
knowledge
for really understanding the positive
impact that hydration has on your body
and your well-being
what do i do to manage my mental health
i think
is carried with us throughout the entire
day from the moment that we
wake up to when we go to sleep um i feel
like we
want to place ourselves in all these
different buckets um and i like to set
those goals
and those buckets can be as easy as
thinking okay today i have my
my small to-do list i want to spend time
with my family
i want to get my work done i want to
take care of my body
but it always starts with myself how am
i feeling am i energized
am i fresh what is my body lacking the
best thing i've learned
in the past year is that you can get too
far ahead of yourself
i think it's important to visualize and
have goals and i've always done
in my life and in my career but
sometimes it's best just to
get things done on the day the quirkiest
thing i do in the name of wellness
a few months ago i did a week at an
ayurvedic spa
i love to eat everything so anytime i'm
just eating plant-based
food and no coffee i feel like i'm doing
something extremely special
the one book that has changed my life
i'm a huge fan of adam grant his way of
connecting
stories to real life experiences and the
way that he puts
his words on paper i find incredible
i would like my legacy to be that i stay
true and and real and authentic to
what i believed in and what i wanted to
represent i played in a very individual
sport i always wanted to be the person
that
a teammate would choose you know to to
get you out onto the field when it
really matters
you